mesdames et messieurs je suis heureux de
voir ici à moscou le ministre note sa
cagnotte qui étaient six en visite
officielle cette visite a été prévu
depuis longtemps
après mon séjour
erevan en avril de l'année dernière j'y
pour concerter toutes nos positions sur
l'agenda bilatéral et international
il ya deux jours nous nous sommes
rencontrés ici à moscou dans le cadre
des contacts tripartites des ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'arménie et
de l'azerbaïdjan et de la russie tenus
sur la position du président composition
du président russe poutine suite à
l'aggravation de la situation dans le
haut karabakh
dès le début des échanges des frappes
la russie est dans le cadre de la ce et
du groupe de minsk a tôt fait pour une
désescalade de la situation et début de
négociations comme vous le savez il ya
eu une déclaration des coprésidents
trois présidents du groupe de minsk et
c'est que la déclaration des envoyés
spéciaux qui sont chargés du règlement
dans le haut karabakh
après une série et des conversations
téléphoniques avec le président ali
revint le premier ministre pas génial le
président russe a lancé une initiative
dans des bus humanitaire qui prévoit des
consultations sur tous les aspects du
règlement 9 et le 10 octobre vous y
avaient assisté peut-être nous avons
tenu une rencontre qui a permis
d'obtenir des ententes
qui ont été publiés diffusé dans le nu
est d'enlever ce et nous nous espérons
que cette trêve serait respectée par
toutes les parties
nous nous sommes échangés sur les
démarches à suivre
ensuite cela ne veut dire ne peut pas
dire que toutes les questions seront
réglées tout de suite
nous comprenons très bien que cela
prendra du temps mais bien sûr faut pas
traîner
il faut continuer les négociations et
comme nos amis arménien âge nous ont
informés dans le cadre du ministre
mnatsakanian on va progresser lors de la
rencontre avec les représentants du
groupe de minsk
nous avons une dynamique de notre
dialogue politique sur le fond des
restrictions dues à la qu'ovide 19 mai
nous avons utilisé le format à distance
le président poutine et le premier
ministre pas génial on tue des contacts
cette fois les chefs des gouvernements
se sont rencontrés à trois reprises en
personne et michele micheline vient
d'achever sa visite à erevan
lors de cette visite il a eu des
entretiens avec le premier ministre
passe géniale
face à cette désastre de la pandémie de
lakovic 19
notre pays fait preuve de la coopération
amicale sur demande de nos amis
arméniens
nous avons livré du matériel médical et
des médicaments
et suite à l'entente au sommet des
ressauts log du ministère de la défense
sont sur place en arménie nous avons
coopéré donc
pour le retour des citoyens russes et
qui se sont retrouvés à l'étranger lors
de la pandémie
soixante dix neuf volets route était
organisée pour rapatrier les arméniens
qui se sont retrouvés en russie nous
avons constaté 20 6% de croissance de
nos échanges commerciaux et malgré les
crises économiques partout dans le monde
qui était en partie dû à la co lead nous
avons réussi à éviter cette baisse des
échanges commerciaux
nos échanges commerciaux sont restés
stables par rapport à l'année dernière
nous nous sommes convenus de concourir
en l'organisation des démarches pour
élargir notre coopération économique et
international par exemple l'organisation
du de la 20ème réunion de notre
commission intergouvernementale
dès que la situation le permet nous
allons organiser le 8e forum russo
arménien a avec la participation de
représentants des dizaines des régions
de la russie et de l'arménie dans le
domaine culturel
nous sommes très satisfaits par la
réalisation du programme de coopération
entre les ministères de la culture pour
les années 21 22 et l'année prochaine je
serai en arménie l'année tribaux id
tribouille adobe nous accordons une
importance à l'apprentissage du russe en
arménie
il ya des filiales de neuf universités
russes qui forment plus de 3 5 mille
étudiants
il ya des quotas
pour la formation des étudiants
arméniens ils sont au nombre de cinq
mille 2000 sont financés par le budget
fédéral
plus de 2000 citoyens arméniens sont en
formation dans des écoles
professionnelles
nous avons parlé bien sûr de l'agenda
international est toute la panoplie de
notre coopération dans le cadre de
l'organisation du traité de coopération
de sécurité dans le cadre des nations
unies du conseil de l'europe et de
l'organisation de la coopération en mer
noire
nous avons mis au point le programme de
consultations entre les ministères des
affaires étrangères pour qu'on sorte et
nos positions internationales
ces pourparlers ont été constructifs
dans une ambiance de confiance je
remercie mon collègue monsieur
mnatsakanian et je suis certain que les
résultats de nos négociations vont te
promouvoir à l'ambiance de notre
confiance et du partenariat qui sont
nécessaires dans cette période difficile
merci merci beaucoup serguei
victorovitch air près représentants de
la presse chers collègues tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier la partie russe et
vous serguei victorovitch principalement
pour votre accueil pour notre dialogue
constructif nous avons eu des
discussions substantielles sur un large
nombre de questions bilatérales et
régionales et mondiales
également nous avons beaucoup d'idées
claires
et sur ce voyage sur cette visite
ce qui prouve le niveau élevé de notre
partenariat russo arménien c'est une
visite officielle à moscou qui avait été
prévu beaucoup de temps avant je suis
très content d'eux d'avoir effectué
maintenant malgré les problèmes qui
existent dans notre région
nous apprécions les efforts de la russie
dans le processus du règlement du
conflit dans le haut karabakh et surtout
danser cet accord du 11 octobre sur le
cessez le feu
notre relation qui se base sur la
coopération à tous niveaux qui comprend
tous les domaines de la vie et dans
toutes ces directions nous avons un
partenariat un dialogue multiforme et
dynamique
ce hacker victorovitch vous a parlé de
l'agenda que nous avons évoqué
aujourd'hui des accords que nous avons
l'intention de promouvoir l'importance
particulière est accordée par nous
allons contacter haut niveau le plus
léger à notre coopération stratégique au
caractère stratégique des relations
russo arménienne
la russie est le principal partenaire
économique arménien notre nos échanges
sont élevés et restent élevés surtout
dans cette période d'instabilité
économique et de la porte dès mi même
malgré la chute de
des activités économiques qui a été
constatée récemment nous sommes
contentes de voir que les tempos restent
les mêmes et que nous avons continué à
effectuer des
des frais apporté des frais et la
coopération économique
ce s'effectue également dans le cadre de
notre commission interparlementaire sac
et victor obinna évoqué justement que
nous allons trouver bientôt une chance
d'avoir une session régulière de cette
commission qui est une plateforme de
base de notre coopération économique
nos pays ont une coopération réussie
dans les formats internationaux
l'arménie est en marbre de l'union
économique eurasiatique et récemment eu
lieu une réunion à erévan d'une
commission spéciale de l'alliance et
nous allons appliquer nos efforts
s'ouvre développer les institutions de
notre organisation qui ce qui devrait
influencer positivement la vie de nos
citoyens notre coopération militaire
avec la russie représente également une
partie très importante de notre travail
commun a été l'une des priorités de
notre agenda bilatéral
donc continuons d'apporter notre
contribution pour améliorer les
le travail de l'organisation du traité
de la sécurité collective et nous
estimons que les principes de la
sécurité collectif et la stabilité sont
une priorité dans ces conditions
mesdames et messieurs nous aurions peut
continuer pendant longtemps et d'évoquer
les relations russo arménienne les
diverses domaine c'est notre coopération
nous vous comprenez aujourd'hui je me
concentre plutôt sur le développement de
la situation qui menace réellement la
sécurité de tout notre région
aujourd'hui nos compatriotes sont face à
cette situation dans le haut karabakh
cette menace existentielle qui existe
depuis quelques dizaines d'années à
partir du 27 septembre ça continue
jusqu'aujourd'hui les dirigeants
politiques et militaires de réserve et
gens effectuent une agression de d'une
large envergure contre le peuple de
carabas et procède à une extension en
physique de la population de artzak
cette manière de ne pas reconnaître la
différence entre les militaires et les
civils vise justement à cible justement
la population civile les forces
militaires de l'azerbaïdjan ont attaqué
plus de 120 localité civile du haut
karabagh notamment des villes densément
populaire la ville de chouchi marc
taquet martouni et setra les forces
militaires de l'azerbaïdjan ignore les
obligations pour faire la différence
entre les cibles militaires et
civile et encore une fois ça prouve que
les forces azerbaïdjanaises le faux
délibérément le font intentionnellement
suite à des frappes avec l'aviation sans
faire la différence entre les civils et
les militaires avec l'application des
drones et du matériau artillerie lourde
et des roquettes
il y a beaucoup de victimes auprès de la
population civile
justement suite à l'utilisation des
munitions des sous munitions
il ya eu beaucoup de pertes les actions
des forces militaires ont fait plus de
100 victimes laissées jeu suite à cette
agression
le nombre des personnes déplacées à
augmenter certains certaines personnes
ont dû déménager dans d'autres localités
de haut karabakh ou en arménie les
infrastructures civiles au contenu des
pertes et des maisons ont été détruits
près de 6000 sites civils ont été
détruits ou sévèrement endommagé 960
sites de production d'infrastructures
d'énergie de connexion de la
communication des maisons de culture des
usines ont été détruits plus de d'une
centaine d'objets énergétiques ont été
endommagées et détruit plus de 10 blocs
énergétique ont été sévèrement
endommagés ou détruits
il ya eu également une destruction
délibérée des sites religieux le 8
octobre pour les forces armées de la srp
gens ont fait deux autres attaques
contre l'église de saint sauveur qui est
une importante
en important centre religieux de haut
karabagh suite à cette attaque des
personnes civiles
on se faire notamment des représentants
de la presse les représentants des
médias ont également été ciblés ces
frappes
pendant ce temps il ya eu des cas des
blessures graves
des journalistes arméniens et
internationaux notamment des
journalistes russes représentants des
médias russes qui ont dû des blessures
assez graves lors de la deuxième frappe
sur le territoire où se trouve cette
cathédrale de saint sauveur j'ai
représenté cette situation en détail et
c'est une preuve du fait qu' il y a une
mine menace existentielle dont nous
parlons depuis des dizaines le peuple du
haut karabakh fait face à cette menace
depuis 30 ans cette menace s'aggrave par
deux facteurs négatifs
à cette étape notamment c'est
l'implication directe de la turquie et
des militants venant de la syrie de la
libye terroristes d
radicaux utilisent sont utilisés par la
turquie pour exporter son influent
instar des régions dans son entourage
c'est un fait prouvé que les militaires
ont été transférés par la turquie et
cela a été évoqué par la communauté
internationale en recourant aux services
des terroristes et turque le haut
karabakh est devenu le centre de
terrorisme international dans notre
région cette politique de soutenir les
organisations terroristes de leur offrir
des couloirs dans le caucase pourrait
donner lieu à une exclusion d'activités
terroristes non seulement de notre
région mais également à ses alentours
aujourd'hui il faut mettre fin à des
affrontements militaires à des
hostilités le rôle de rue de la russie
est particulièrement important je
voudrais souligner encore une fois
l'importance de notre future déclaration
commune que nous avons réussi à avoir il
ya deux jours si seulement je voudrais
remercier encore une fois la russie pour
son rôle actif et surtout le monsieur
vladimir poutine pour son implication
actif active dans ce travail
serguei victorovitch vous aussi je vous
remercie pour votre travail
grâce à notre travail commun nous avons
réussi à obtenir cette déclaration
commune qui a pour but de mettre fin aux
hostilités et de dos puis les milieux
d'avoir la trêve pour l'instant nous ne
pouvons pas constater que nous avons
réellement eu un haut niveau un
substantif des changements la zirp
agents ne respecte pas ses obligations
de cessez le feu
je voudrais aussi noté l'importance des
mécanismes de vérification qui pourrait
permettre de respecter respecter le
cessez-le-feu
seulement une fois le régime de cessez
le feu
réussi nous pourrons progresser et
avancer dans d'autres questions
l'arménie a toujours été et reste et
respectueux s quant aux mesures de
négociation dans le règlement du conflit
dans le haut-karabakh nous allons
promouvoir cela par notre travail cergy
victorovitch à noter qu'aujourd'hui et
demain j'aurai des réunions avec nos
collègues et coprésident du groupe de
minsk nous allons continuer dans ce sens
d'autres de travailler pour faire en
sorte que cette frappe qui a été
opérée contre les efforts de paix il
faut tenir compte de cette situation et
de cette influence très négative de ses
actions et nous devrions résoudre cette
question
l'arménie pour le haut karabakh est le
seul garant de la sécurité et nous
allons continuer à appliquer tout pour
les efforts faits pour garantir tous les
droits
jack le tueur au caire a pas pour
chasser tous les terroristes et ceux qui
les couvrent dans cette région je suis
pour eux je sais c'est en force négative
je voudrais encore une fois vous
remercier sa guitare aux biches pour
votre accueil chaleureux pour nos
négociations constructives substantielle
nous allons continuer à discuter au
cours de cette journée
je voudrais vous remercier pour votre
contribution personnelle pour le
renforcement de notre coopération entre
la russie et l'arménie
le renforcement de nos bases de
relations merci la télévision publique
de l'arménie l'agression d'envergure de
l'azerbaïdjan contre l'euro karabakh
s'accompagne par des frappes ciblées
contre la population au civil elle est
de qualité il ya des destruction de
l'infrastructure
comment vous voyez les solutions qui ont
fait l'objet des accords ou bien vous
envisager d'autres options de ce
règlement pour préciser vous dites nous
envisageons d'autres options nous avons
confirmé avec le ministre arménien notre
attachement des ententes qui ont été
obtenues samedi dernier bien sûr il faut
arrêter tout de suite les frappes
garantir la vérification de la trêve
procéder à un échange de prisonniers et
aussi des corps des tués et reprendre le
processus
2b sur les principes de règlement qui
ont été envisagées c'est la position de
la russie et de l'arménie il n'y a pas
d'autre option
la russie et l'arménie bien sûr la
russie 24
vu les événements des deux derniers
jours quand les deux parties s'accusent
de violer la trêve comment vous voyez ce
mécanisme de vérification qui
permettrait de respecter le régime de
cessez-le-feu
et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
aux accusations de la sepanso qui sont à
adresser à l'arménie et qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour quand même respecter le
cessez-le-feu aux mécanismes de
vérification pour l'instant je préfère
des précautions en ce sens qu'il ya des
consultations concrètes sur ce sujet à
présent justement sur la base de deux ce
qui a été dit par la déclaration commune
selon cette déclaration notre tâche
prioritaire c'est le cessez le feu et
les mécanismes de vérification
aujourd'hui nous avons la situation où
nous n'avons pas encore parvenu à voir
le niveau où nous pourrions passer à
[Musique]
mettre en oeuvre le premier point de
notre déclaration se maintenant nous
travaillons avec la participation de la
croix rouge et les parties avec la
métier de progression
de la russie pour trouver des mécanismes
travailler concrètement les coprésidents
ils sont impliqués directement également
tous les trois coprésidents pour
commencer le travail pour créer une base
solide pour un cessez le feu sur et pour
passer aux questions humanitaires si
nous n'arrivons pas à prolonger cette
trêve cela continuera à influencer
négativement toutes les questions donc
s'assurer ce processus de trêve c'est
notre tâche prioritaire à présent voilà
pourquoi les douves ya l'importance des
mécanismes de vérification ce n'est pas
la première fois que nous le disons s'il
ya des accusations à l'égard de
l'arménie ou à l'écart du haut karabagh
nous disons toujours qu'il est bien le
moment de d'entretenir ces mécanismes de
vérification il est beaucoup de
propositions dans ce sens nous aurions
dû le faire depuis longtemps mais ce
n'est pas la partie arménienne du haut
karabakh qui ont réfusé mais c'est la
partie azerbaïdjanaise qui avait
prononcé à le faire c'est valable pour
quoi nous avons cette situation
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas accepter
ces accusations dans le contexte de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui d'arménie a
toujours été le garant de la sécurité du
haut karabagh et s'il n'y a pas d'autres
systèmes pour le haut karabakh 17
questions de lutte pour gras son
existence c'est plus qu'une réalité
aujourd'hui il en donnait ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
merci proposer ce que j'ai répondu à
toutes les questions
je confirme que le contrôle du respect
du cessez-le-feu
c'est une question clé une question est
très importante dans les conversations
téléphoniques les du président poutine
avec
le président azerbaïdjanais et le
premier ministre arménien heures à la
veille de notre rencontre de samedi
ils ont parlé de la vérification comment
sur le terrain on va vérifier le
cessez-le-feu et comme vous le savez
dans notre déclaration conjointe adoptée
le 10 octobre
nous avons souligné que les mécanismes
de contrôle feront objet des
consultations complémentaires
vu la situation très grave dans le haut
karabakh et autour du haut karabakh vu
la gravité de ce problème
il s'agit par exemple de des prisonniers
de guerre des corps des tués ne faut pas
traîner avec la mise en place de ces
mécanismes de vérification le travail
est en cours la russie y participe les
coprésidents du groupe de minsk y
participent également
et aussi la croix rouge internationale
est prête à participer à ce travail
dès que la situation soit stable
surclasse concernant la participation de
la russie dans le règlement nous allons
prendre une position active en tant que
l'un des coprésidents du groupe de minsk
et puisque les rues si c'est un allié
proche et est le partenaire stratégique
de nos voisins et je pense que non et
quoi session de nuit que se sont soldées
à part document très important ce
n'était pas une chose vaine toute façon
nous allons régler la situation dans les
jours est très proche
nous sommes très intéressés dans ce
règlement comme tout est parti agence e
spoutnik
bonjour agence spoutnik
la question à deux ministres le
président azerbaïdjanais et estime que
la turquie devrait jouer un rôle plus
actif dans le règlement dans le haut
karabakh est ce que pour vous cette
participation d'ankara dans le groupe de
minsk et de l'eau et ce pourrait
promouvoir le règlement est est ce que
on peut parler d'autres formats puisque
dans votre déclaration conjointe à ces
voyants et arménie ont confirmé leur
attachement à ce format des négociations
messieurs la drogue est-ce que la russie
continue à avoir des contacts avec la
turquie et commvault caractérisé la
position de la turquie vous avez raison
vous avez dit que dans la déclaration
conjointe l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan ont
confirmé l'invariabilité du format de
ces négociations le groupe de minsk de
l'osce est ce c'est un groupe de groupes
de pays très nombreux qui a délégué ses
pouvoirs à trois pays la france et les
états unis et la russie
les trois coprésidents et durant les
derniers jours
toutes les déclarations des trois
capitales ont confirmé l'attachement à
ce mandat des coprésidents c'est ce que
nous faisons avec maintenant non deux
partenaires la france et les états unis
les représentants de la france et des
états unis sont maintenant à moscou et
il s'attend de la rencontre avec le
ministre mnatsakanian jeudi dernier ils
ont eu des contacts à genève avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères de
l'azerbaïdjan et donc nous confirmons la
variabilité de ce format des
négociations et dans notre déclaration
conjointe tripartite
nous avons confirmé notre attachement
aux efforts
à la base des principes qui ont été mis
au point avec la participation des trois
coprésidents je crois que c'est une
réponse exhaustive
je confirme que le président aliev a
salué la déclaration conjointe de moscow
suite à notre travail d'une vie j'ai
parlé avec le ministre turc des affaires
étrangères monsieur chavo choclo et j'ai
souligné que nous comptons sur le
soutien de la turquie de nos affaires et
fort nous avons eu encore une autre
conversation téléphonique
maintenant il faut que ce mécanisme soit
opérationnel c'est ce que nous faisons
actuellement
je pourrais ajouter que oui
effectivement le soutien de ce format
est exprimé par cette déclaration
commune
du 10 sur 10 octobre coprésidents du
groupe de minsk sont en effet le seul
format efficace qui travaillent sur le
règlement pacifique et cela n'a jamais
suscité de doute pour nous surtout
maintenant cela ne suscite aucun doute
nous allons continuer à travailler
activement dans ce format nous avons
déjà évoqué que je tire un contact
aujourd'hui et vous comprenez comprenez
ce que ce qui se passe notamment dans le
haut karabakh à présent c'est ça
agression flagrante et l'état dans
lequel se trouve au karabagh cela
influence gravement la situation mais
notre travail va continuer parce que
notre position reste toujours la même
il n'y a pas d'alternative au règlement
pacifique si l'azerbaïdjan a choisi l
option de du recours à la force en tant
que méthode de parvenir à des conditions
promouvoir ses positions maximalistes il
n'y aura pas de règlement pacifique et
il n'y aura pas de paix dans la région
cette méthode sera rejetée radicalement
nous allons travailler nous avons
l'intention de le faire travailler avec
les coprésidents ce qui concerne le rôle
proactif de la turquie et excusez moi
mais pour l'instant son rôle proactif
c'est se manifeste par la présence des
militants terroristes dans notre
territoire et par son soutien militaire
à l'azerbaïdjan qui est vous le
comprenez naturellement ne pourrait pas
être utile cet activiste ce genre
d'activités merci merci merci et bonne
journée